what's going on everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things Marvel all things you
and Spider-Man no way home when we got
the official full length trailer did not
disappoint I actually didn't want to see
Toby or Andrew in the official trailer I
want to see them for the first time on
screen You know despite all the leaks
that we've had but I think this trailer
was perfect it showed so much and there
is a lot to break down now I've only
watched it a few times I'm gonna watch
it a few more times as I go through and
look at the footage and break it down
I'm gonna be doing a lot of videos about
this trailer throughout the week so be
sure to subscribe hit that notification
Bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos and so you can enter our
Spider-Man collectible giveaway me and
Chris over at cosmiculture giving away
one all you gotta do to enter subscribe
to my channel subscribe to Chris's
Channel Cosmic culture and leave some
comments on some recent videos alright
there's a lot to break down in this
trailer so let's get started so the
first thing I want to mention and talk
about is no Toby and Andrew were not in
this trailer but I am happy that that is
the case however there are very clear
signs in this footage that this trailer
has been edited and to me I actually
think we've found the scene where Toby
and Andrew are in and you can see that
one of the other two Spider-Man is
actually hitting lizard in one of the
scenes let me show you in the scene
towards the end of the trailer where our
Peter Parker our Spider-Man is fighting
against the villains we only see one
Spider-Man and we see all of the
villains or at least most of them jump
towards Peter we have Electro the
Sandman and the lizard attacking Peter
but if you look at the scene right here
when the lizard is jumping in the middle
of the air he randomly gets hit the only
problem here with this scene is that
nothing hits him nothing at all he kind
of just throws his head to the side but
it is very clear that he is getting hit
and if I end up stuttering a lot in this
breakdown sorry I'm just really excited
about the trailer still but again it's
very clear that the lizard is getting
hit by something so what I think is
probably probably Happening Here is that
the three Spider-Man are going up
against these three villains with each
Spider-Man fighting one specific villain
now they are obviously not going to show
us the other two Spider-Man that is what
they've been trying to avoid doing for a
very long time but I'm willing to bet
that that is exactly what is happening
here because it's very clear something
or should I say someone is hitting the
lizard and I'm betting it's another
Spider-Man also another very important
part of this trailer is that Dr Otto
Octavius Doc Ock acknowledges that our
Peter Parker is not the same Peter
Parker as his therefore Toby Maguire's
Peter Parker is technically acknowledged
here
bugger to acknowledge that Tom Holland
is not the same Peter Parker from his
universe as to acknowledge that Toby
Maguire is the Peter Parker from his
universe so little hints like these
little small details tell us that Toby
and Andrew are coming and then let's
talk about the very final scene with
Doctor Strange we see a lot of mystical
stuff going on and it kind of looks like
the Multiverse is shattering Dr strain
says they're starting to come through
and I can't stop them now right away
what I believe is happening here is that
the villains are actually trying to
bring more villains from different
universes into this universe more on
that in a bit but what this tells me is
that Peter Parker and Doctor Strange
cannot do this alone Doctor Strange
literally says I can't stop them then
Peter Parker himself are Tom Holland
Peter Parker even says this is all my
fault I can't save everyone again
implying that Peter is going to need
some help in which he will get in the
form of two other Spider-Man and I think
that this could perhaps be the time
where the other two Spider-Man do get
brought into this universe Dr Strange
can't stop other people from coming in
why would it only be bad guys perhaps
the good guys would come as well and I
think that is what's going to happen in
this scene if not earlier in the movie
so yes I firmly do believe that Toby and
Andrew are 100 in this movie I think
they've been edited out of some scenes
in this trailer but let's get started on
some other really important scenes now
the first scene is Peter talking to MJ
and he actually mentions getting bit by
the spider something that we really
haven't heard much of in the MCU they
skipped the whole origin story when they
introduced Peter in Captain America
Civil War and then in his own film
homecoming and he tells MJ there's only
one week that he's ever felt normal
where his life has felt normal and he
says that week was the week that MJ
found out that he was Spider-Man now of
course it looks like our Peter Parker
got to work right away when he got these
Powers doing good like he talked about
in Captain America's Civil War taking on
the responsibility but what I think they
could be doing here is foreshadowing
this scene is made to imply that MJ is
kind of the best thing in his life with
the exception of maybe Aunt May but
she's the one that makes everything
better now I hope this isn't the case
but it could be foreshadowing perhaps
her death or maybe her forgetting that
Peter is Spider-Man at the very end or
maybe even forgetting that she knows him
again I hope not but a little bit of
foreshadow in here then it shows us some
web slinging footage which we haven't
got a ton of in the cityscape so far
with the Spider-Man homecoming franchise
but here he has MJ and they're going
through the subway tunnels so this is
literally picking up right where
Spider-Man far from home left off in
that post-credit scene where he's with
MJ everybody knows that he's Spider-Man
he's going to pick her up and they're
going to run now here's where we really
find out about the main plot we know
from the last trailer that Peter Parker
goes to Doctor Strange to get him to do
a spell to make everybody forget that he
is Spider-Man and we know that Peter
Parker opened his mouth one too many
times while Doctor Strange was doing the
spell also Wong mentioned that the spell
was pretty dangerous and he warned
strange to not do that spell but of
course they did it anyways and it got
messed up and now Doctor Strange tells
us exactly what happened he says when
you botched that spell implying that
Peter is the one that indeed messed it
up where you wanted everyone to forget
that Peter Parker is Spider-Man we
started getting some visitors now if
you've been following my Channel or if
you've been trying to keep up to date
with Spider-Man no way home you know
that these other visitors Green Goblin
Doc Ock Electro the Sandman and the
lizard are from other universes and
Doctor Strange confirms that here he
actually says we're getting visitors
from every Universe now we do know where
the villains are coming from from what
we know Doc Ock and Willem dafoe's Green
Goblin are indeed from the Sam Raimi
Toby McGuire Universe it is rumored that
Sandman is from the same universe as
well obviously coming from Spider-Man 3.
then the lizard and Electro are from The
Amazing Spider-Man universe with Andrew
Garfield again all of the villains are
coming from Toby and Andrew's universe
so of course it would make sense that
they would come from their universes as
well and be in this main Universe to
help our Peter Parker whether or not
they came by choice or not now as Dr
Strange mentioned some visitors come in
we get several clips of villains we see
the pumpkin bombs that we saw from the
last trailer but this time we actually
get a full reveal of the Green Goblin
again this will be Willem dafoe's Green
Goblin from the Spider-Man Toby Maguire
Universe we see his pumpkin bomb then we
see him come through the smoke full
outfit even the helmet on his glider and
if you look closely you can see that
this is the exact same suit that Willem
Dafoe wore in Spider-Man 1. then we
don't get a shot of Electro per se that
comes later on in the trailer Jamie Foxx
but we do get his lightning he's
shooting lightning at Peter and we get a
really good look at Peter Parker's new
black and gold suit now fun fact about
this black and gold suit I actually
exclusively reported where the black
suit actually comes from on my website
thecosmic wonder.com I also posted it on
my Instagram and Twitter so if you're
not following me on there you should
sometimes I post things that I don't put
in videos and based off of what I've
learned the black and gold suit is
simply his red and black gold suit
turned inside out during the beginning
of Spider-Man no way home a person who
supports Mysterio will run up to Peter
Parker as Spider-Man in the street and
throw green paint on him because he
supports Mysterio this causes Peter to
flip his suit inside out and inside out
all the circuitry shows for the suit
which is why it has the gold circuitry
in it this is much like what happened in
Spider-Man Homecoming in homecoming we
saw Peter Parker's Tony Stark suit
inside out and if you look closely you
can see the golden circuitry and the
black that is what we are seeing here
with the Spider-Man black and gold suit
then we get new footage of Doc Ock
fighting Spider-Man on the infamous
bridge but we actually get the fight
scene Doc Ock shows up and says hello
Peter but after unmasking him and
getting a close-up look he realizes this
is not Toby McGuire's Peter Parker he is
in a different universe and there is a
different Peter Parker Tom Holland's
Peter Parker and he says to him you're
not Peter Parker I lost my mind in this
scene like I mentioned before his Peter
Parker is Toby Maguire and him and the
film are acknowledging that right here
in the scene to me this is a huge
confirmation that Toby is indeed coming
now the next part is very very important
after they fight on the bridge we cut to
a scene where docok is in a prison in
Doctor Strange's sanctum this is
actually the same location where Doctor
Strange would do the spell and there has
been leaked concept art out there that
shows all the villains actually being
trapped inside of the cell they each get
their own individual cells and of course
they're making sure to truly introduce
Doc Ock here Peter and Jay and Ned ask
what his name is he says Dr Otto
Octavius in which they all laugh and
this really reminds me of the scene in
Infinity War where Peter is saying oh
we're using our made-up names now from
here several really important key of
events happen Dr Strange says there are
others out there other villains but I'm
also thinking he could be referring to
other Spider-Man as well but when he
says others they do show the villains we
get a look at a new Statue of Liberty
being built to hold a Captain America
shield some leaks have told us that this
is where the final fight will take place
and later on in the trailer it does show
Spider-Man fighting Electro Sandman and
the lizard on top of it so strange says
there are others out there and we need
to send them back and we get a look at
Electro in the background behind
Spider-Man in his black and gold suit
which is now Enchanted by Magic as you
can see in his right arm Doctor Strange
has Enchanted the suit obviously he does
this to help Peter Parker be able to
fight all of these different villains
since there are so many he also probably
granted the suit some powers to be able
to trap them now here we get a brief
scene of what Doctor Strange is kind of
like as a mentor he says it's all
Peter's fart and we need to Scooby-Doo
this crap and Zendaya kind of talks back
to him in which he says please
Scooby-Doo this crap now here is
possibly the biggest and most important
part of this trailer we find out why the
villains are attacking Spider-Man we
hear doc ox say you're flying out into
the darkness to fight ghosts in which
Peter replies what do you mean in which
doctor strange explains they all die
referring to the villains fighting
Spider-Man it's their fate now obviously
our Peter Parker Tom Holland has never
met or fought any of these people let
alone killed them so Doctor Strange
apparently knows here they've all died
to other Peter Parkers specifically
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield Doc
Ock in the Toby Maguire Sam Raymond
Universe died to Toby Maguire's Peter
Parker kind of at least in Spider-Man 2
Willem de fuzz Green Goblin definitely
died at the hands of Tobey Maguire's
Peter Parker in the very first
Spider-Man film and then of course you
have Jamie Foxx's Electro and the lizard
dying at the hands of Andrew Garfield's
Peter Parker the only one that's kind of
interesting is sandman he didn't
actually die in Spider-Man 3 to Toby
Maguire he actually left on really good
terms Toby Maguire said I forgive you
and then he went away and for this exact
reason it leads me to believe that
perhaps this Sandman may not be from the
Toby Maguire Sam raymie universe but
we'll have to wait and see on that now
as Doctor Strange explains this we do
see some footage of Peter fighting some
villains and simply some villains
causing chaos and what I believe is the
point where they all enter this universe
we can see Sandman and Electro are
definitely there because we can see the
sand on the left side the lightning on
the right side and some purple in the
background which is what I believe is
the entry point to where they came to
this universe because at the end of the
trailer we see all of that purple and Dr
Strange says they're coming in now the
NYPD arrived at the scene along with JJJ
Jonah Jameson on the scene we can see
The Daily Bugle on the van we then see
Peter jumping after a pumpkin bomb
obviously trying to save somebody that
it's being thrown at and what's
interesting here is that he's actually
not wearing a helmet he's not wearing
the face covering with a nanotech suit
this is most likely what results in the
scene that we saw where he's really
really beat up and the bomb is probably
thrown at MJ or Ned I'm gonna assume
it's MJ maybe one of the other
Spider-Man but probably MJ but here's
where it gets really good doctor strange
says I'm sorry kid and Peter says yeah
me too in which doctor strange looks at
him and says don't but then Peter Parker
webs up this Cube that doctor strange is
holding and takes it now I've done a few
videos talking about a real plot leak
that is out there that I've seen that
has been confirmed true if you've been
following me you've seen this and you've
heard about this Cube don't worry if you
haven't I'll explain it right now this
cube is apparently a key not only to the
prison that all of the villains are in
but a key to sending them back to their
respective universes and making sure
nobody else comes into our universe the
MCU from other universes like the
villains already have done now according
to this plot leak the cube eventually
breaks and that's why Dr Strange at the
end says I can't stop him but Peter
takes this Cube because he feels guilty
that these villains died at the hand of
another Spider-Man he fills a ton of
guilt because of this and thinks that
maybe he can perhaps change it somehow
and they don't have to die also while
the villains are apparently in their
cells the Green Goblin Willem dafoes
Green Goblin Norman Osborne tries to
talk to him and kind of convinces him
that they're actually good and they just
want another chance and this is why
combined with the guilt Peter Parker
takes the cube from Doctor Strange
however if you're gonna try and take
something from the masterofthemistic
Arts Doctor Strange you better be ready
to fight because that's exactly what
happens when Peter takes the cube they
fight and Doctor Strange clearly wins
here but then Peter says don't there has
to be another way in which strain says
there isn't there a danger to our
universe now from here we get a lot of
really cool scenes now at 156 in the
trailer if you look really quickly
there's a scene of Aunt May running
really frantically this could actually
be the scene where Green Goblin has
thrown one of his pumpkin bombs he could
have thrown it at Aunt May looking back
at that scene this very well could be
the case after all Willem defoe's Green
Goblin did use Aunt May as bait in the
very first Spider-Man film as well looks
like Norman Osborne could be doing that
again because of course he knows that
Peter Parker is Spider-Man we then have
the scene where Doc Ock has Peter
wrapped up in his arms we were showed
this photo a couple of weeks ago on the
bridge of course but here's a very very
cool scene we can see Doc Ock actually
taking the Nanobots from the iron spider
suit a couple of weeks ago we did get a
photo released where Doc Ock had the red
on his tentacles and I told you it was
from the iron spider suit but some
people doubted me Greg from the real
rejects but that was what I was told and
now this definitely confirms it as we
can literally see the Nanobots on his
tentacles we then see something insanely
cool Jamie Foxx's Electro is back he
looks completely different different
which I love and he actually looks comic
accurate if you take a look it's very
brief we can see the lightning forming
around his head in that star pattern
that looks exactly like a comic Electro
looks like I love that they're doing
that this is our first Jamie Foxx reveal
even though he spoiled it like a year
and a half ago but he says you're not
going to take this away from me most
likely referring to the fact that he is
now alive and has a second chance
because he dies in The Amazing
Spider-Man 2. obviously him and the
other villains aren't just going to let
Doctor Strange send them back to where
they will just die again because that's
exactly what will happen so they're not
going out without a fight but here at
202 in the trailer we actually see
something rather interesting we see a
lightning bolt kind of hit Doc Ock and
Doc Ock Falls now again at the end of
Sam raimi's Spider-Man 2 Doc Ock kind of
turns good and he sacrifices himself to
save everybody from himself but still he
doesn't he finds out Peter Parker is
Spider-Man and he has a change of heart
and says I will not go down I will not
die a monster and seemingly turns good
perhaps that is something that we could
see happen again in this film maybe Doc
Ock turns good and this is Electro
fighting against him Maybe not maybe
this is some sort of a mishap but it
does look like Electro hits Doc Ock
pretty hard we then see Peter on top of
the Statue of Liberty that is being
reconstructed to have Captain America's
shield on it he's fighting Electro when
he jumps off and notice in his hand he
still has that cube the cube apparently
gets damaged during the fight of strange
and Peter but it looks like it could go
on to get repaired somewhat because it
looks like that's what they're going to
use in the final battle to try and get
them all to go back to their respective
universes we then hear very clearly
Willem dafoe's voice the Green Goblin
saying Peter you're struggling to have
everything you want while the world
tries to make you choose now what I
believe this is is the Green Goblin
Norman Osborne in a prison cell in
Doctor Strange's sanctum and this is
where I believe Norman Osborne is trying
to talk to Peter and try and talk some
sense into him and this is where he kind
of convinces Peter to let all of them go
and makes him feel bad that they all
died to Spider-Man now honestly I'm
really worried about happy I think he
might actually die in this movie but
we'll have to wait and see on that but
then comes the big edited money shot
there's some type of an explosion on top
of the constructed Statue of Liberty as
far as what that is we're not sure
perhaps the villains are indeed trying
to bring more villains into this
universe so they can take it over I
doubt they're trying to get back because
as we know they'll die but check this
out Peter says this is all my fault I
can't save everybody and which I've
already explained that I think this is
where the other Spider-Man come I
believe they come in Via a sling ring
but that's all I'll say about that to
avoid Major Spoilers but in the main
trailer that Sony released on their main
YouTube page and on their Twitter we see
Spider-Man going up against Sandman
Electro and the lizard now the clip that
I showed you in the beginning where the
lizard is get getting hit in the face
out of nowhere that is actually only in
the Brazilian trailer in this trailer
right here we don't see the lizard
getting hit at all so that's a slip up
by Sony right there but there is
something very interesting about this
scene as you can see Electro and the
lizard aren't going anywhere near
Spider-Man Electro is jumping up the
lizard is jumping down and to the side
of Peter Parker and it seems very clear
that there are other Spider-Man 2
specifically in this shot that have been
edited out to not be revealed in this
trailer this scene right here just seems
very evident the lizard isn't going
anywhere near Spider-Man that combined
with the Brazilian trailer showing the
lizard getting hit by a ghost
essentially that confirms it right there
the other Spider-Man are in this film so
the three of them fight Electro Sandman
and the lizard and the shield that is
being built on the Statue of Liberty
ends up breaking and the building ends
up collapsing in which MJ starts to fall
and here is what I think is actually
happening here this fall looks a lot
like when Gwen Stacy died in The Amazing
Spider-Man 2 looks a lot like it we then
see Tom Holland's Peter Parker jump
after her and it looks like he's gonna
end up catching her however I don't
think it's Tom Holland's Peter Parker
that saves her I think it's Andrews I
think this is his big Redemption moment
right here I think he couldn't save his
Gwen in his universe but he can save MJ
in this universe and if this doesn't
happen I think it's a really big missed
opportunity but after watching this
trailer I have full confidence in Marvel
and Sony that they know what they're
doing the trailer ends with strange
saying that they're coming through and I
can't stop them this really could be
anything but right now I'm thinking that
it's just more villains or other
universes colliding with their own which
would make a lot of sense considering
that we're about to go into the
Multiverse of Madness I think other
universes are colliding here and that's
where everything's going to pick up in
Multiverse of Madness and is is going to
make for a heck of an ending and
hopefully this also means that Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield could be
sticking around for a while but that was
the official full trailer for Spider-Man
no way home I loved every single second
of it please let me know what you
thought about it in the comments down
below thank you all so much for
supporting me and my channel through
this time it's been amazing all the
Spider-Man news has been fantastic I
hope you continue to support us even
when it's gone even though it will be
said and of course you can follow me on
social media Instagram Twitter and Tick
Tock I post there sometimes it means a
lot when you follow me you can find me
on there thanks again for the support
and as always I love you all woof woof